Wow yeah you know its tricks in this
rule people just want to get ahead and
make money and they take advantage of
people yeah it's really sad but I want
to talk about this business Tiger belly
mm-hmm
this business is growing slightly put
some work into it and there's some
payoff a little bit and but it's still
difficult for me to even talk to people
about it really what do you mean well if
I'd like the other day I was in a room
in the mint and I was in the greenroom
backstage at the main room and I saw Joe
Rogan and Bill burr were back there you
see hi but in my head still especially
with those two there's a thing in my
head you know just I use in my head yeah
it has nothing to do with reality it's
just a little tape recorder that I press
play when I'm around certain people you
know but then you like hey you know you
hug them whatever and they were happy to
see you and what none but I can't get
myself to go come do my podcast because
you're just never gonna be that type of
person who asks ya ever ever ever you're
just not that that we've asked you like
you've had people in front of you say
hey Bobby let me do your podcast and you
said okay and then I remind you hey
sweetie text so-and-so who wanted to do
our podcast no I can't ask they asked
you first and you can't even ask him
back because there's a there's a there's
an expiration date on that if you don't
do it okay so if they do it or me like
you're talking about Steven Yeun yeah
Steven you just [ __ ] say it then lady
he said I'd be happy to do your podcast
and you were like cool and then you just
never hit him up again - because it's
inspiration x'
expiration date and also i don't ever
want to seem like I'm needy okay
you mean like I need you to do a please
the only reason why Jordan worked was
because he attacks to be the night
before right and he was like he eluded
the fact
maybe he would want to do our podcast so
it was like a window that I was
completely open to me but here's also
I'm also very close to him well we were
you know so I know him but like what
Steven Yeun is like I've I've you know
he knows my brother and David and stuff
but and I I whenever I see him it's very
pleasant I really like the kid he's
talented kid and he's nice it's just
that I just don't know him the way I
know certain people that's all yeah but
it's you you also you have to also think
of it as we don't need anyone in this
podcast ever we do just fine
you know just the four of us but so you
have to think about it that we don't
need these big people we want to have
them because he is Korea and he is
relevant he is going to have the types
of conversations that we like to talk
about in the podcast about being a
minority and stuff like I didn't being
in the industry that those things are
things we'd like to talk about I
understand that and was I'm gonna make
you a promise guys okay and I promise I
have a feeling that maybe if things go
well that this pilot that I did god gets
picked up okay I do I'm only mentioning
in mentioning it is because at that
point I would feel like I have more
power to do it
City Hall Eric Stonestreet and go ahead
can do it you know can I also ask you a
question I really I feel like I need to
get invited into the club I don't think
you'll ever feel ready for that no your
very self you know how you say it like
you
III think even if you were at the very
top of the game you're always going to
feel that little voice you hear that
little voice in your head that tells you
you're not in the club you're just that
person no I've been to the club you got
the club yeah what club that's what I'm
saying listen to me mmm there is a
feeling and a part of being a part of a
club that you just I don't I know that
I'm not will ever feel like I'm a part
of the club I just want to get the
invite okay oh I see so once I get the
invite
to the club I'll stick my toe in and go
and back in right just to let people
know that hey I got ax after a decade of
not being in the club I got myself back
in the club yeah right and then I will
leave weird Bobby go I go I'm out of the
club now 20 the show got canceled yeah
right but what I'm saying is is that
there is a feeling and and I understand
like when I see someone like Ron Funches
Pontius write really funny he's very
funny and I love him nicest guy in the
world right but he you could tell in his
eyes right that he's a part of the club
right now mm-hmm
and I and I look at him I don't say it
out loud but I give him a wink like
you're in the club no I'm not in the
club but I go I know I know where you
going you're going right now into the
club the clubhouse and that need tells
his friends that Bobby keeps a wiki and
what it is is this is that they're just
things that you get right like I'll give
you an example when I got this pilot I
went to my trailer and I just had boxes
of kif's like what from my agents right
they give you a scooter or whatever it
might be I've got scooters I have set
out to raise her right I've literally
gotten a scooter before I don't think I
don't scooters come in no they they give
you a card where you can go to this give
a number on it right and you can go this
is my code and then they deliver it
whatever right I just don't want to ride
a scooter they'll die you're you're a
careerist then you're 100 who yourself
value hinges on the work that you're
currently no Macaulay Culkin left the
business he was because he was born into
the club oh yeah
no here at babied you're not getting
what I'm saying okay
all I am saying is is that it's like I
just want to go in one more time you buy
it and look at people and go
remember me I was once here and I came
back and now I'm leaving but just let
them be aware that you know I might be
back again can I say something as being
a really avid ex club goer yeah
the people that get in are the people
who show who don't show that they want
to get in do don't show in neediness
there's always the girls who wearing
super super like tight stuff and the
dudes who are wearing you know they're
the extra shine their shoes with the
button ups and those are the people that
you know you don't want in the club the
ones who get in that scenario you know
what I am I have notes kirtan I have to
smile is he hanging out you're that
desperate to get in the club it's like
I'm on my back in line with my [ __ ]
ladies open my lips open right anyone
doesn't matter stick your feet in yeah
yeah but it's always the people who look
like they don't need to be in the club's
who get into the club use a secret for
you
people believe I think that I'm not
desperate even though I am so I've been
able to hide it but sometimes I see you
like when you see go ahead say it say
that long like when you talk to Joe or
bill burr like there's an extra like
your voice becomes higher and I'll nudge
him but don't be needy don't talk about
the UFC with yeah yeah yeah yeah just be
cool bro
[Music]